YOU DID NOTHING AND ALL THESE
OTHER INCIDENTS, ALL TALK.
51 YEARS OF BLABBERING.
DON’T FORGET LAST WEEK BY AN
ACCUSED FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OF "EGREGIOUS TACTICS."
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT SAID THEY
WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR ATTACKING
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS.
THAT’S NOT AT ALL WHAT HAPPENED.
JERRY NADLER, HE MIGHT’VE OUT ON
THE EVER CONFUSED BIDEN AND GONE
A STEP FURTHER CALLING VIOLENCE
IN PLACES LIKE PORTLAND A MESS.
EVERYTHING WE’VE BEEN SHOWING
YOU, DON’T LEAVE YOUR OWN EYES.
BELIEVE THIS PSYCHO.
>> VIOLENCE ACROSS THE WHOLE
COUNTRY.
THE VIOLENCE HAPPENING IN
PORTLAND.
>> THAT IS A MYTH BEING SPREAD
ONLY IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> ABOUT ANTIFA AND PORTLAND?
>> YES.
>> THERE IS VIDEO EVERYWHERE
ONLINE.
FIRES AND RIOTS.
THROWING FIREWORKS AT OFFICERS.
LOOK ONLINE.
IT’S CRAZY.
>> Sean: OKAY, WE HAVE THE
CONGENITAL LIAR SCHIFF AND
NADLER, TWO OF THE BIGGEST LIARS
TELL YOU THAT THIS IS REAL.